what do you call a blemish that you
exchange letters with a pimple pimple I
got one BAM you see it I see it we all
see it for ice cream probably because of
ice cream is probably from sugar haha no
I'm gonna turn the brightness up a
little bit but that don't mean you can't
see this thing shines bright like a
diamond
my name is Chris Habib didn't know know
you know but if it's different now I
have a zit that won't quit on my
forehead and it made me think I've never
made a video that I can remember about
how to cover up a pimple everyone seems
to have their particular methods for
covering up blemishes and let me tell
you I got methods I'm using items that
you can probably find in your house
already or at some sort of drugstore or
Party City let's get started
headband a flower crown a sleep mask a
hat a tiny hat novelty sunglasses third
eye third eye eyepatch Phantom of the
Opera mass under around your head that
you give them a raging bachelor party
you don't owe anyone an explanation as
to why you will not take it off actually
I party bridal veil wait one dick
forever a wig a tiny mirror so that
those who choose to judge you can take a
look at themselves you just decided to
over draw your eyebrows today they reek
are deviled eggs just tell everyone
you're a DJ pelegrin you blacked out at
a party at least you got invited to a
party sunglasses that flip pop just
never flip them back down turn it into
forehead freckles say Coachella dramatic
hand placement dramatic emo bang you
were in a bar fight you're cool
a towel sub when you lost the bet and
you had to get a really shitty forehead
tattoo a casual morphsuit well there you
go there are some ways that you can
cover up your nasty pimple what you call
blemish that chooses an edgier fashion
style nasty pimp cow okay if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up and do
not forget to subscribe to this YouTube
channel click that button down below in
it that bill notifications so you know
when I post videos as of now it's
Tuesdays and Thursdays and I hope you're
enjoying it other than that I don't know
oh this pretty much my brand